-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated comedian
who will be returning as
guest host of "The Daily Show"
next week on Comedy Central,
and her memoir,
"Leslie [Bleep] Jones,"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show,
our good friend,
Leslie [Bleep] Jones, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
[ Cheering ]
Yeah.
If you got it, you got it.
Flaunt it.
-My stylist said, "Make sure
that you show the leg, bitch."
-Yeah.
[ Cheering ]
-I've been lucky enough
to talk to you
about this book
a couple of times now.
You did a wonderful book event
in New York City.
You came on a podcast
with me and my brother
and can I say --
-You're so sweet.
-Oh, I love you.
-Seth loves me!
-I will say,
we did a book event.
-We should have a baby.
-What?
-Nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Sighs ]
-Did you see how he reacted?
Like we had really did
something.
Like, "You pregnant?"
-I mean,
the book event went well.
I don't remember going
that well.
I would say, it was
a great symphony space
on the Upper West Side,
and I feel like
a lot of those people
go to book events
on the Upper West Side,
and I think it was
they've never heard answers
about a book that you gave
at that book event.
-I loved it so much.
-Yeah?
-You had no control over me.
-No, I almost never do.
Now, did your editors have
control over you in your book?
-No. Absolutely not.
Absolutely not.
They kept asking for it.
They were like,
"Are you finished?"
No, I'm not finished.
-Did they fight you on the title
or was the title...?
-They fought me on everything.
-Yeah.
-Look, okay, there's a deadline.
There's a deadline and I --
yeah, blew the deadline.
Yeah.
I reread the whole book
and rewrote the whole book,
and they was like,
"You can't do that."
It's my book. I can do whatever
the [bleep] I want to!
[ Cheering ]
-I want to know --
I've heard people --
You did something, though
I have not heard
anyone say they've done before
when you talk about,
you can't be controlled,
even you couldn't control you,
because you, when you went in
to do the audiobook,
you admitted you wouldn't
even read it
the way you wrote it.
-Okay.
-It went just like this.
It went just like this.
"Foreword.
When Leslie --" No.
First, what had happened was --
[ Laughter ]
-And the editor was like,
"I made her take out
all the
what had happened wases."
-Yo, yo, the director was like,
"Um, I don't know, maybe we --"
I was like, "Girl,
this is how it's going, girl.
I'm not finna sit here
and read this book and be like,
'Oh, Leslie Jones,
she said that she --'
But since a cop had --'"
No, I know the story,
and I'm finna
give you the details.
I'm going to give you
the real tea.
They didn't put that in there.
They was trying to hide it.
Let me tell you.
I think it's the rarest case
where, you know, like,
sometimes when I'll be --
I'll like, read a book
on like, my Kindle and then
I'll switch over to Audible.
When you go back, it's like,
"you were on this page."
I feel like with your book,
it'd be like, "We don't know.
We don't know where you are.
We don't know what to tell you."
-I was like, "Just ride with me.
Tell me if I go too deep."
And there was some stories
I would go so deep in it,
she'd be like, "Um, Leslie,
we're -- we're only in
Chapter 2 and we're over.
It's over, that whole chapter."
And I was like,
"No, I got more to say."
So I thought it was
only 7 hours.
I come to find out
it's 16 hours long.
[ Laughter ]
-It's the "War and Peace"
of audio memoirs.
Now, I want to get --
real talk here.
You actually wrote this memoir,
and you had to go back
and you had to remember things,
and you maybe had to revisit
tougher times in your life.
Was it cathartic
to go back to those things?
Was it difficult, ever,
to go back to the past?
-Oh, of course,
because now you look and I go,
"Oh, my God,
I made it through that?
Oh, my God, how did I not die?
Oh, my God,
why would I say that?
Oh, my God!"
It was a lot of stuff in there,
I was like,
"Girl, you can't say that.
Oh, you have to take that out."
And then there was
a lot of things --
because, you know,
I smoke weed,
so I don't remember
a lot of stuff
and oh, my God.
You know Dina, right?
You know
her last name was Moles?
-Uh-huh, Dina Moles, yeah.
-I call her Morales.
Her new name is Morales.
-Okay, so you called her
he wrong name in the book?
-There's so many things.
So my coach hit me,
and he was like, "Yeah,
that's that's not
exactly how I went."
I was like,
"It's how I remembered it."
That's how I started saying it.
I was like, "Well,
this is the story I remember."
No, it's really pretty accurate.
[ Laughter ]
-You talk about some people --
Look, you came across, you know,
you broke into "SNL"
later in your career
than maybe other people,
but you met
a lot of very successful
people over your path,
and some of them
gave you a lot of advice.
Some told you about the value
of getting life experience
as well, outside of
just getting onstage.
What were some of the things
you did that were helpful?
-Yeah, I just went
to a lot of jobs.
I had a lot of jobs,
a lot of jobs.
Yeah, I got fired a lot.
-Yeah.
I -- yeah --
Did I ever I quit?
I quit, but yeah. No.
-Did you do a lot of, like,
"You can't fire me, I quit,"
because that doesn't count.
-No, I was
never in that situation.
It was always like,
"You can go."
Like, "We're going
to let you go now."
It was always like,
"Oh, we can't keep you on."
"Uh,
going a different direction."
Or, "Just get out."
Like, you know?
-Looking back,
do you think in most
of those cases
they were right to
send you home?
-Yes, absolutely.
Oh, my God, one job,
I used to --
I thought I was going
to be a receptionist.
[ Laughing loudly ]
It's hilarious, right?
[ Laughs ] I couldn't
even answer the phone.
I think it was
a construction company.
I'd be like,
"Alpha Construction."
And the girl was like,
"You got to be more..."
I was like,
"Alpha Construction."
And they would come to --
Man, I would go to sleep.
I would go to sleep at the desk.
[ Laughter ]
Because I did comedy
the night before,
and I was like,
"Man, I'm finna take a nap."
"You are the receptionist.
You can't take a nap."
So I won a contest
and I came in the next day
and I was bragging, like,
"I won this contest.
I won $1,000 in this contest."
And they was like, "Oh, great."
And the girl called me
in the office.
She was like, you know,
"I'm so glad
that the comedy is going well...
because we're going to have
to let you go."
-When she heard
you won a contest,
she was like,
"Today is the day."
-Today is the perfect day.
-The window opened a little bit.
-Oh, I clowned, too.
-I was like, "Oh, bitch,
I'm finna be famous!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You should go back
with all the money you have now.
You should buy that desk
and use it to take naps on now.
-They ain't open no more.
-They ain't open no more?
Well, yeah. Nobody there
to answer the phones.
Hey, this is very exciting.
Next week,
you were the first guest host
when "The Daily Show"
started doing this
and you get to go back,
do a second week.
You were fantastic, fantastic
the first time.
[ Cheering ]
-Yes.
Are you excited? And my other,
just quick follow-up --
do you feel like you understand
it a little bit more
going into it now,
having done a week?
-Oh first of all, it's so ran
like a well-oiled machine.
-They know what they're doing.
-They'd make anybody look good.
I'm going to be honest with you.
They make anybody look good.
Their writers over there
are just like, big brains.
They're just --
They just, like,
some of the stuff?
I love it.
I love it over there.
And I love to
be able to express,
because I feel like I'm just
like the people's people.
I understand
what they understand.
Like, I don't know
if you saw that
that I thought that
the Electoral College
was where the politicians
go to college.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And they learn college stuff,
you know what I mean?
They learn, you know,
it's a whole class.
So I was like,
how you gonna know
what the Constitution say?
So, you know, I was explained
that that's not right.
-Yeah.
-So it's like, stuff like that.
It's a lot of stuff that
people are not informed about.
And I feel like you
get to watch MSNBC
and CNN and get all of that.
Now come here so I can
make you laugh about it.
That's what I want,
to make people laugh.
You guys need to laugh, man.
Y'all not laughing.
[ Applause ]
Y'all just so sad.
Everybody's so sad right now.
And it's just like,
we as comedians,
me as a comedian
I feel a big debt
to this world right now
to bring some joy.
Like, it's not all hopeless,
I promise.
[ Applause ]
And I know.
Listen, listen,
I know that you're like,
"Oh, bitch, you're rich,
and blah, blah, blah,
and you can't tell me,
blah, blah, blah."
Yes, I can.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have to have hope.
You have to believe
in yourself
and in the people that you --
We have to work together
and we have to be uncomfortable.
That is the problem.
We're not doing anything
because we're complacent
and we're comfortable.
We have to be uncomfortable
to fix some of this [bleep].
You know what I'm saying?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Real talk.
Get your ass up and vote.
Only a third of the country
is voting.
If 60 people are in the room
and only 20 are ordering food,
guess what you gonna eat?
What the 20 people ordered!
Pick your [bleep] menu up!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, I disagree
with everything she just said.
Another really cool thing,
before you go, everybody here
in the audience tonight --
talking about bringing joy --
is going to get a copy
of Leslie's book.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-We'll be right back
with Judd Apatow.
There's nobody like her!